I have with me today Jeb Bush the former
governor of Florida who when he was
governor saw the greatest improvement in
student performance of any state in the
United States that was between 1998 and
2006 and one of the things that he did
as governor was to address the problem
of teacher quality
Jeb there's a lot of problems in
American education today and one of them
is that the conning quality of teachers
it used to be that we recruited a lot of
teachers from the very best schools in
the country it's harder to do that today
there is Teach for America which is
bringing a lot of talented people into
the teaching profession but in general
it's very difficult to get their very
best college graduates to go into
teaching so what were some of the things
that you did in Florida and what are
some of the things that could be done to
enhance the quality of the teaching
profession well thank you Paul it's
always a joy to be with you you're one
of the experts that that takes data and
analyzes it and does the kind of
research that allows policy makers to
implement policies and that's what I got
to do as governor in Florida we had a
growing student population and a
teaching cadre of that was diverse of
course because fleurs a diverse state
but a lot of a lot of teachers that
we're nearing the end of their career
because of just the aging of our
population so sixty thousand teachers a
students a year combining with a
declining teacher population required us
to act before other states the more
students fewer teachers yeah not a good
plan yeah there was not a good plan at
all so what did we do well we opened up
our system we have these antiquated
certification programs that exist in the
country that were designed literally 100
years ago and the schools of Education
had robust programs back in the day but
they've de-emphasized that and so we've
we've created reciprocity for all
anybody that is credentialed as a
teacher in any state can come teach in
Florida this was one of the real
obstacles to teachers who want
had to move for months agent all of a
sudden lost their job and couldn't get
it back the system was designed to
protect the existing teachers it was a
protectionist system and we opened it up
I think other things that are important
to do is if you have if your subject
matter expert if you're an engineer and
you want to teach math in the old days
you couldn't do that you had to go back
to school just exactly where the
shortages are in math and science so if
you in Florida if you're a
subject-matter expert you can get an a
temporary certification to teach and
we've streamlined the process to be able
to get a permanent certification paying
more for the for the places where you
have shortages is part of this so and
paying people paying teachers for rising
student achievement so if you want to
build a professional teaching cadre you
got to have professional development but
you also have to pay the extraordinary
teachers more so they stay in the
classroom we tend to have a lockstep
teaching exactly payment schedule and so
Washington DC is the best example of
this where teachers could opt out of the
traditional collective bargaining
process which is a step plan based on
how long you were there to dramatic
increases in spending for student for
teachers that had great peer reviews by
their fellow teachers by the principal
who's the CEO of the school of course
and by test scores for students and the
implementation of test scores as part of
this I think is essential part of this
now in Florida we did something else we
bonus teachers outside of the collective
bargaining agreement for schools that
show improvement or a rated they get in
effect $100 per student the school does
and that goes back in the form of a
bonus to the school personnel it's 150
million dollars a year in Florida if a
teacher begins to teach AP classes the
school gets rewarded with higher points
for higher grade and the teacher gets
$50 per student for students that pass
does that have any effect on your AP oh
my god moment I would have space what a
surprise we've had three hundred three
digit percentage increases particularly
in the schools that never had a
p-class so the prime beneficiaries would
have been low-income students and
teachers get on average you know if
they're really on and this they get up
to $3,000
similarly for career certifications so
rewarding teachers for dealing with the
the things you want which is making sure
that students are able to take advanced
courses and dealing with the shortages
as it relates to effective teachers and
low-performing schools teachers in the
STEM related areas a market orientation
in essence is what has to be done in
Florida began that process so paid look
if teachers do a good job you know you
don't want to leave the classroom you
want to reward them but not for inputs
not for being there for a long time
there's some great teachers that have
been there 30 years but there's also
some that aren't that good why not why
not reward people for rising student
achievement is there any way to
discourage the ineffective teachers from
remaining in the profession that's
something that I'd be blown about this
yes yeah yeah you can fire them no you
can in Florida okay other states
elimination of tenure was one of the
elements that we did and for teachers
that have been in the classroom they
have to earn their tenure by not you
know by evaluations that show that
they're satisfactory or excellent
teachers
there should be no teacher after
remediation that cannot cannot deliver
rising student achievement in the
classroom because it's so dangerous for
students and also mediation you do you
think is appropriate is that one year I
think it's a year in the probation it
probably varies but you have the Flores
system it's three years of performance
data for student learning so you're
taking an average over three years which
i think is fair and then if if they are
below average significant below average
they they can lose their tenure and all
new teachers have no tenure at all so
the the system needs to move to a
professional system not to a collective
bargaining system that's basically a
trade union teachers I think are
deserving of higher pay and we're
deserving families are and our country
is deserving of rising
achievement so take Korea Korea pays
significantly high teacher salaries and
they finance it by higher class sizes in
places in this country we think class
sizes the determining factor for student
achievement no it's it's its quality
teachers so you're saying we could get
better teachers and better schools if we
didn't worry too much about having
extremely small classes class sizes
there's no there's no indication I just
read your research there's no indication
that it yields rising student
achievement but an effective teacher in
front of a student for a multi-year
period delivers and that's what we
should be doing
I'm not saying let's just cram students
in classes for no purpose but wouldn't
it be better to pay teachers more for a
job well done and one of the ways you
could do that is not have these mandated
lower class sizes as as the norm in many
parts of the carbon imagine that we're
going to have a great educational system
without great teachers and so these
ideas are ideas that we have to do more
than just talk about we have to do
something about it yeah and the people
interestingly that opposed this
generally are the unions that represent
teachers and other school personnel
which is a tragedy because in reality
it's hard to get buy-in from the union
leadership but teachers desperately want
to be recognized as professionals and if
they do extraordinary work they want to
be recognized not just in terms of a pat
on the back you know what's wrong with
providing them bonuses and higher pay
for the job they do they have such a
critical job it is the one thing that
matters as it relates to whether a
child's going to learn well thank you
very much governor good to have you with
us today thanks Paul
you
you